we live in the richest society in all of
human history like our lives are so good
and you're gonna [ __ ] because you
weren't offered freaking rugby or nine
if there weren't people that did that
like we would still be let's say like
some countries in the middle east like
obviously there's some women that had to
say oh hang on i want to drive and then
things change so i want to return that
i'm like done driving
women are better drivers though you have
to admit no not
they're not they they have less
accidents but it's only because men
drive
more actually like per yeah and men
actually drive more dangerously yes i
would say yeah so women are better but
the thing is but the thing is women take
less risks driving so they're better no
but it depends on what you mean as
better because no i think
that's what i thought it was too but i
want to say they just disproved it and
they said that actually men are better
drivers
men have less accidents for how much
they drive right
okay so then when you were saying that
women are better drivers why is it there
on this is not a formula one women's
race because like why is there nothing
women's things
that's a different type of driving
i'm saying
for me to get from a to b
i'm the better driver
because i'm i actually who gave you this
title as yourself and insurance
companies the insurance companies
insurance companies before this is why i
don't know but it's because women drive
it's because women drive less that's why
so if you do something less there's
going to be less accidents mm-hmm so as
i say where i don't like feminists is
they complain about things that actually
benefit are you just disregarding the
fact that she just told you that what
would be driverless i i don't know i'm
not saying because i don't know if
that's true she just disproved what you
just said and you would completely stick
it with yours
where did you get that from okay wait
wait wait how did she disprove what i
just because she explained that women
are having less accidents because
they're driving less
yeah so that and that's what i don't
know when you when you compare it
it just means that you drive less and
you have less accidents meaning that
you're a better driver so why do
insurance companies because they drive
more charges they drive less and like
they're right
risk when it comes to insurance
if you have a lower risk if like a taxi
driver is going to have a higher a
higher premium than a regular person
because you're on the road more more
okay like truck drivers truck drivers
are mostly men yeah their premiums for
their um insurance must be really high
because just out of share numbers you're
on the road all the time you're more
likely to have an accident yeah it's
like i've got classic car insurance and
they will give you a low insurance
because they limit the amount of mileage
so they say oh you can only drive that
car a certain amount of miles and that's
why it's lower well it makes sense
every time i see someone like cut me off
or do something crazy it's always a girl
it's never a dude it's always like a
girl on her phone like
and like doing something wild swerving
in the intersection
i still don't see how that would like
benefit insurers if genuinely women were
worse drivers even if they were less
okay so women have more accidents for
how much they drive so it benefits that
or less accidents because they drive
less right so it benefits them because
if i'm just going to take a man and a
woman at large right the the woman is
less likely to have an accident i still
got her money so if you drive like no
but you don't have to pay out insurance
companies don't have to pay out keep
your money yeah
okay so they'll be paying off more risk
one at a time
companies only deal with risk that's
nice
so there's more risk the more you drive
yeah okay
now can i ask
a random question um
it's on topic but do men as men do you
feel like
men should only speak amongst men when
it comes to
um like matters of
importance let's say do you feel like do
you feel like when men speak in public
what they're said what they're what
they're saying is taken as seriously as
women
talking about emotionally emotional
stuff oh and seriously you you you keep
that you keep that
to yourself and you're close
close circle yeah because um
girls don't want to hear that [ __ ]
they don't want to hear that they don't
want to hear
about you know whether your your fears
your insecurities whatever you're going
through you you work on that [ __ ]
yourself and you present
the company front
and that's you know that's what you got
to do
it's just
it's just the way it goes
and then you know you have to be there
for your boys when they're going through
it i mean i had to go through with a
friend of mine
you know he had to go to family court
and you know
emotionally you know go through all
these emotions about his daughter and
everything else
and you know
as a mature man you got to be there for
your boys and go you know when they want
to talk even when they're crying and
still hold that respect but
you know i could see when he was having
those interactions with
his significant other
it was causing friction
and you can't say to him hey man
we can but in a gentle way look
if there's any [ __ ] come to me
we could talk it through without
judgment
but you got to present because he's his
girlfriend his partner wants him to be
that strong leader
and she can't she
because she doesn't know what it takes
to be a leader in a male sense the
concept of him showing any kind of
weakness is like completely alien right
whereas
i know okay cool you're going to have
those quiet moments to yourself
where you know you're going to
you know you have to deal with whatever
you're going to deal with because life
love can be harsh
you know what's interesting that i
noticed so if a guy hits a girl what's
the immediate reaction
he shouldn't have done that
now what's the immediate reaction if a
girl hits a guy she shouldn't have done
that what did he do what did he do
that's exactly that that's exactly what
people say or or basic mind yeah
definitely society was that what would
he do yeah or even um
cheating songs like next time maybe
he'll think before he cheats you know
like and then she's literally vandalism
but if a guy does that to a girl he's
seen this crazy
insane but if a girl
is out your car yeah that's that's
that's
that's what jasmine sullivan said yeah
i'll bust the windows at your car she
also evolved they've listened to her
journey to her music now
she flipped that yeah but you don't but
you don't give that benefit of the doubt
chris brown
like chris brown right like chris like
chris brown nobody says oh he's evolved
that people still complain that he
performs and stuff even though rihanna
hit him first i mean yeah yeah she hit
him first with that whole i mean that
whole concept the people that want to
hold on to that to the past of that
that's really their business because if
you even watch his documentary about the
whole thing you see he's evolved if you
see how he's progressed but a lot of a
lot of women like to harvest onto the
past and not move on and that's
definitely an issue that we have as
women and that's what you see on social
media when people want to redeem
themselves and want to come back and be
different well that's why the johnny
depp case was so prominent wasn't it
because it showed women in a different
light yeah i mean but initially when she
came out and said he was an abuser
everyone believed her but that was
stupid yeah but the thing is it's like
that's that
whole thing with men of you know do we
get taken seriously it's like no women
do
well there's believe all women yeah
that's the most sexist thing i've ever
heard in my life believe all women why
the hell would i believe you just
because you're a woman you could be just
as crazy as the man can be yeah
i think you should believe